Okay, in this lesson we will talk about spam
or unwanted commercial email. Now, you might not think
that you receive a lot of spam but the
fact of the matter is that most of it goes
to your spam folder. So one might think what's
the problem? Well, in fact, spam remains a scourge for
network operators. In particular, someone has to design the
filters that separate the good traffic from the bad traffic.
Additionally, even if email is classified as spam,
if it's accepted for delivery, the internet's mail
protocols dictate that the server has to keep
the mail. Because it's told the receiver that it
has accepted the mail. This creates the potential
for spam to consume a significant amount of
storage space on email servers. Finally, spam can
create security problems for users who receive spam emails.
If the spam messages contain a payload that could
be harmful such as malware or a phishing attack,
or an attempt to steal a user's private or
sensitive information, such as a password. Now even though
you don't see the mail because of these filters,
something like 95% of all email traffic is spam.
Some reports from the Anti-phishing Working Group suggest that
something like one in 87 emails was a phishing
attack and there's something like 50,000 unique
phishing attacks in a month. A common approach
for getting rid of spam messages is to
filter. In other words, prevent the message from
reaching the user's inbox in the first place. Now this begs the question of how
to differentiate spam, or the bad messages, from
ham, or the legitimate messages. There are three
different ways to construct filters. One is content-based. In
other words, you can look at what's being said in
the mail. For example, if the mail contains particular words,
such as Viagra or Rolex, a content-based filter might pick
up on those terms and decide to filter the mail.
Second, a filter might make a decision about whether an
email message is spam or ham based on the IP
address of the sender. This method is often called blacklisting.
Third, we can construct filter based on behavioral features,
or how the mail is sent. So for example,
if the mail is sent at a particular time of day, or if it's sent in a batch of
emails that are all roughly the same size, then
we may be able to figure out that a message
is likely spam simply based on the sender's sending
behavior. Now each of these approaches are complementary, but content-based
filtering and IP-based filtering each have problems.
Content-based filters are relatively easy for attackers
to evade. A recent large commercial mail operator recently told me that he saw
something like 80,000 different spellings of Viagra.
But additionally, messages can be carried not
only in texts, but in images, Excel
spreadsheets, or even mp3s or movies. Therefore,
spammers can easily alter the features of an email's content and adjust those
features and change them to evade content based filters. On the flip side, those
maintaining the filters suffer a relatively high
cost because the filters must be continually
updated as content changes and the means
of carrying the content become more sophisticated.